شاكيرا وبيكيه لسه موجودين في قوائم
اهتمامات الناس حول العالم هذه الايام
والسبب تطورات قصتهم وتبادل ردات الفعل
فمن بعد ما طرحت شاكيرا اغنيتها اللي قلبت
الدنيا والمشاهدات واعتبرت انتقام موسيقي
للنجمه من شريكها السابق اللي انفصلت عنه
بعد عشر سنوات بسبب خيانه لها مع فتاه
عمرها 23 سنه فغنت شاكيرا وقالت كثير
وقليل ولكن من ابرز ما قالته بدلت
الفيراري بتونجو
فيكي حاولي يمتص الصدمه والصفه القويه هذه
ويحولها لمكسب فشفنا كيف راح اعلن عن
التعاقد مع شركه كاسيو وطلع مدح في
ساعاتهم وقال هذه ساعات تدوم مدى الحياه
وهذا الرد يبدو انه ما كان الوحيد في جعبه
اللاعب فبعد فيديو كاسيو شفنا هذا الفيديو
لوصوله لمقر الدوري
مثل ما شفته في الفيديو فيكي وصل
سيارات وينجو وهي السياره اللي بتصنعها
رينو وشبهت شاكيرا صاحبه بيكي الجديده
فيها في الاغنيه لما قالت له بدل فراري
توينكو طبعا قصدها انه هي شاكيرا الفيراري
وبيك رد بانه ظهر سائق تونجو طيب
الموضوع دخلت فيه كمان
شاكيرا اللي بالمناسبه هي وام جيران مشغل
الاغنيه على العالي ليل نهار بس كده كمان
حاطه على البلكونه المواجهه المنزل
لا لا لا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في تقرير
الساحره وتوقف الاغاني والمه شاكيرا عموما
علاقه الثنائي من زمان مو قد كده وكان في
كلام انه يعني الام كانت معه علاقتهم كون
شاكيرا اكبر من ابنها باكثر من 10 سنين
وكانت شايفه انه شاكيرا مهتمه بمسيرتها
الغنائيه اكثر من ابنها هذا غير انها من
وقت ما ابناء صاحب البنت الجديده هذه وبده
يخرج معها في العلن وهي والعائله محتضنها
ومرحبين فيها تماما طيب وغير كل هذا شاكير
على حساباتها
تتفرج على فيك
الاغنيه الجديده وارقامها القياسيه
الاغنيه صار عليها اكثر من 100 24 مليون
واحد وعمرها 45 وبعدين سنه وبغنيه
بالاسباني وقالت انه هذه الاغنيه كانت
منفس وراح لها وانه نفسها تحضن كل نساء
العالم اللي بيساندوا وبيدافعوا عن بعض
امور نساء اللي بيحطموا وبيحسسوا بعض انهم
مو مهمين طبعا يعني لاحظتوا الدقه هنا
رجعت في الفستان كمان شاكيرا وقالت انها
مو مصدقه انه اغنيتها صارت اسرع اغنيه
اسبانيه في التاريخ بتحقق هذه المشاهدات
على اليوتيوب وقالت محتاجه احد يقرصني على
شان اصدق
[موسيقى]